This is mr. Ivan stenson who worked
on the bridge as a young man as
a boy do you remember those times i went
to do it was. Around nine hundred twenty
seven. It was about the same time as the
duke and duchess of york came out here. It
was soon after that that i applied to work
on the harbour bridge and i was able to
join the people there and. I started as
a rivet heater. And. That sort
of stuck with me for six months or more
and. Then i graduated from that onto
catching the rivets. And
with the with the tongs i
think that i could throw still throw
a rivet as far as the anybody else at
the moment out and. We used to have
to say i think between us to see just how
far we could throw rivet and you could
see these rivets hurling through the air
and catch of the other end or that i'll
forego and kerosene it in with the wouldn't
you know. So it wouldn't go right to
the ten catching it plucking it out with
these tongs putting in the rivet hole
ready for the hole. Up to put his dolly on
it and the. Well i make it into rivet it
down. The. Had various size rivets in in
thickness from about five eight up to him
out into three eight. And the smaller of
its of course was for the latticework on
the the foot walk you might notice they
have
a latticework on the railings of the
foot works and the. And of the main
roadway. And then the big rivets of course
were used in the bottom chords of the
harbour bridge which go from one skew
back across to the other. Later on i from
the. Han river thing i
was transferred over to
a gantry which is a. Sort of
a mobile. Crane on
a wheel on the ground and will up on the
rail of the the wall of the workshop
which has been like
a gigantic horseshoe. And they all the
various ones that some operated these
riveting machines were operated by others
were operated by hydraulic. Water over
the water was up to about a
thousand pounds and if you had
a nine inch ram and i gave
you. Nine times out of about
a twelve inch ram and goes you talk times
that pressure which they use the big one
for the the rivets which were inch and
a quarter inch and three eight up to fourteen
inches long. And after they were put
in you had to go back over your work. You
had to remove all the bolts that that
were in there holding the plates together
and knock out the drips. Then go back and
fill those holes up after the. The
rivets it killed our own there had
a rivet inspector come along. He was imply
buoyed by the government and he just tap
all that if it's one way. Holy swing against
their the rivet tap it if it was loose
he put
a cross on it. They'd have to come out. And
be they'd have to cross cut the head of
the rivet and then drive it out. And
then you would have it was put in. The
. These sometimes the on the revving on
the gantries the the boys or some of the
fellows used to have jokes on the other
four fellows working around there for
a chap came in the wintertime with the
code on you know you hang it up on the
gantry. And they'd put
a. Big bolt and flat big flat why should
which is just scrap steel which would be
about three inches in diameter.
And then tied up with
a spanner about three
foot long and then bird
a thread over so that you were spent some
time when the knock off was went well in
those days the bag that you used for carrying
you know gear in your lunch and that
sort of thing was a gladstone
bag a lot no doubt
a lot of you people might remember
a gradstein being around but the half dozen
isn't that doesn't it. Yes said and.
Used to leave that on the machine of course
and if you always somebody fill it up
with with
a flat washers and bolts and that sort of
thing in nearly put your arm out when you
guessed it. Grab it is
a go but. In my day. Also they used the
world your boots to the plate for me leave
them. Or nailed your shoes to the floor
and. From that position there where i was
sitting on the gantry i used to see various
things around the place and i remember
one day. Chip i am
a christmas who was only or about twenty
or thirty peter way for me. And he had
a bit of angle iron about or nine
inches by nine inches in about
eight feet long. When he was grinding the
end of it and he let it chatter. And with
a grinding wheel of about twelve inches
diameter. It doesn't do that any good and
just burst him straight in the
stomach. Which to you came a bit of
a tummy ache for
a few weeks and put him in hospital. And
right alongside me on the other side
was
a small rail which they used to push the
completed work on little trolleys on these
rails from the light shop to the heavy
shop and that was curved. And there was
a stack of of steel plates.
Up to about inch in
thickness and about six inches six
feet wide and twenty feet long and as
they were pushing this you one day about
thirty or forty fellas pushing these
finish girder through the filler didn't
take into account that the curve would
squeeze him against these plates which it
didn't and it nearly tore his shoulder or
. And nothing happened.
The big. Cleats that they
used to lift the girders with need be twelve
inches by twelve inches and they have
a great big. Turnbuckle with
a crane to pick them up and attempted
just undoing this thing on the side not
thinking what are you doing. For the last
bowled out and the thing fell straight
down of his ankle was just about to keys
put off. But those were the nasty things
that i knew that did happen. And
some of the humorous things. The was
a. One of the boilermakers used to have
a wall. I that is when i point. Upwards i
want points downward sort of thing and in
opposite directions. And i used to have
a watch which i used to
keep in his vest pocket
a young fellow used to go up and ask him
the time. And he used to pull the pocket
hour but his pulley watch out with his
right hand look up on the end get tell you
the time. The kids
thought this was a great
a year you know. There's various
other little things that
that used to happen. One christmas
time there. The the raffle
a lot of chooks and in the light shop before
the they were making up the plates to
be made into girders they had
a guillotine. With two fly wheels which
would be about nine feet and i am it on
either end and they shout about.
Nine inches connecting the two. And
they used to put these plates of about.
Inch and up to i think there were about
into one half in there and they'd
be about ten feet wide. And by
standing on the the lever in the
disengaged of the the guillotine. And
i'm still there. You could hear the
guillotine engage it when you're at manly and
how far away and it is take three quarters
of an hour for the wheels to the play
was to run down. And some
of the boys were feeling
a bit mary and they won the chooks and they
were trying to decapitate the chooks on
these. But they were took smiling
all round the lights up on that day
. But. There were some very
interesting characters down there.
Here's one chap one particular. Englishman
i suppose i shouldn't call him promise
to grow as we might hear me. Oh well
i'm a farm. If not you can call me
a. He used to when he used to go to work
in the morning is to have two tins of
tobacco he was in those age it was mostly
roll your own. One was empty and one had
tobacco and he used to toss up heads for
the empty one tales for the one with
tobacco in. And if he got the empty
one. He'd be humming cigarettes all
. The other thing about them
too that you noticed after
a while. They'd be out here for about
twelve or eighteen months and they'd be
getting complaining about how cold it was
here. So they go home to england. twelve
months they be back and they said do
you bloody cold over there. Now the
population of on the harbour bridge
in the workshops where i was scotch
irish and english. And
here along in amongst the
irish there was some pretty wild characters
i can tell you feel as if forward in
the black and down wall. And i just can't
think of the name of the couple of these
fellows but i'm just going back
a few years though it's hard
to remember names and there's
a few names i do remember. And. The
. One of the holder ups or the more or less
you know i suppose in modern days you'd
call him
a tradesman assistant was at an italian
by the name of joe. Tara or his full name
was joe gondar tara. And he was one of the
strongest men i've seen i've seen him
lift weights that you know two men and be
staggering and in the book with this big
weight. And. The. How much that they
use down there were from seven fourteen
twenty eight and fifty six pound hammers
and he swing a fifty six
pound hammers if it was
a fourteen pound however. He
was truly a strong man and
a very nice person with it. He was
a thorough gentleman in every respect. And
i did learn later after he finished on
the harbour bridge he went back
to his old trade which was
a gunsmith. He had that shop out at newtown.
I never did catch up with him again i
would have liked to. But.
As you know. Things.
People got
a bit scattered after the. The finish
of work on the harbour bridge and
the great depression was on then and the
people lot of the people who worked on the
harbour bridge went up to
new guinea because he was
a big project going up there now particularly
for the boilermakers that at that
time they were going up there to work.
It dave over and went up there amongst
others. Yes he did too. Its main
effect. I was only looking at
a photo of dave the other this morning.
In the some of the pictures that have got
of the harbour bridge and you know he
looked about thirty of them. And he's irish
how do you know i have
a crown on it. And. The
. And just blanked out for
a moment. Does matter. Do you remember what
happened to you when you were laid off
or what but what year. What time of the
year was soon after the arch was locked.
That was in no i'm sorry.
That's how it was in thirty one
that i finished there. Around about much
thirty one. So where were you when the
whole bridge was opened. I was in sydney i
was living at chatswood at the time and
. When it was open. Because
like everybody else went for
a walk across the bridge on the opening
night. Now thousands of people just walking
across
a bridge the.
I've just run out of words. I mean.
What about did you did you go to get
a job after the whole bridge and they were
very few and far between. You'd get in
a queue. You know
a couple of hundred yards long and by the
time you got there. They were very very
selective what's experience to be
had having had an experience where
a lot of things you didn't have experience
in those days because you know more is
fresh out of school and going to
a job like out and for any thing outside
and what you were doing. Well you didn't
have the experience for and they were very
very selective. You said do all sorts of
odd jobs around the place and
gradually i was able to you know keep
myself occupied. And one of the things
that i did notice about which i think
that they're
a lot of the unions and poor people
they could follow was i can only recall
one day that we had a
strike or it is not so much
a strike. It was
a twenty four hour. Stoppage. There was
a case in the united states that two
italians by when sacco and vanzetti
. They were going to be executed on
a particular day. For
a crime that it supposed to be in committed.
About seven years before. And the
evidence that convicted them
was somebody saw them in
a car passing at sixty mile an hour eighty
years ago for. That was even though
there were. They were convicted on and
executed. So i think it was worldwide that
they had the twenty four hour stoppage.
And that was the only thing i can recall
sure we used to have a union meetings
and things like that. But there was
a lot more tolerance still to what
you were doing in those days and.
You were known worker won't you in the
ironworkers union at the time. Do you
remember the union meetings in that year
i remember those and they weren't as
numerous as they do know you don't have to
drop you had to cool meeting whom. Like
they do now but they were few
and far more tween. And.
They used to help them outside on the
wharf where the bought the stuff in from
england from don and
long. The winters were
very very cool there because there
was no virtually no sides to the
workshops and used to have to get all the
breezes on the particular disabilities
coming off them where the heavy shop is now
it's course where the luna park is and
where the. Olympic pool is. For the
people who who you know might want to
know where the workshops where. And one
works up there were not in straight line
with each other but as i explained before
there they were about. I suppose fifteen
degrees difference between the two of
them in the in the angle. And that on the
lower exit to the the light workshop was
then milton's point station and muslims
point ferry terminal. That's where the
ferries used to come and everybody used to
get off there and get onto the train to
walk up there with the latest to the tram
as which used to run then. Do you
remember the when they moved
there when they moved the railway station
from the end of millicent's point to
build the workshops. I remember the first
of all the railway station the original
rail was tatian finished.
Always at where the northern
ireland is now and then they moved it
around to where half way round till eleven
obey there and. Of course the railway
line is still there which they use
for the. For the trains for hunting and
that sort of thing from those in the and
wave at them. Yes i have seen pictures
of course but i was only only just born
then that i used to get
a lot of news in that into the workshop
because i did mostly night shift there and
people coming in it. Tell you on the news
of the day and when they people were
coming in very very gloomily.
Because there had been
a very very bad for reaction of the
great cliff. That's when the heat.
Rolled over and sank it. And then
you see at the news of the smart
a cup trophies and things like catching
people coming in. Give you the news. Of the
time you got how many eleven o'clock or
how past eleven. You'll be getting out of
the place thing you go want to sleep cause
your social activities were restricted
more or less two weekends and. There were
a number of. Rollovers worked with each
other down there was my brother he was
there for some time. Then there with. Some
irish lad by the name of thompson there
was dave and joe thomas and then there was
a string for as the father and the two
sons horry and jim strength alone and
in some cases it was also
a family affair. Did you did you go out
together and sometimes when you were off
duty. Oh yes yes we used the particular
string fellows and then the baby thomas and
navy thompson and i
used to go to the royal
a lot in those days of dancing and you
know we channel the cockies where probably
people remember the various legs that were
around then different sides but that was
it how meeting place under the cockies. And
we used to go to the beach and you know
the various days you ax around on the beach
and that sort of thing when the chap
selling there was he was very good at that
and you know you used to swing him over
your head and all sorts of
things. But it was. It was
really happy days. I suppose in
a lot of respects because that's before you
start to have to really settle down and
care about. The greater things in
life. He was single then. Yes i
was seeing your years and what age were
you when you started and finished on the
harbour bridge. I was. I
suppose i could be fifteen
fifteen the half and i finished when i
was eighteen. In my teens and i find
i was there three and
a half years in him. Where did you live.
How did you get to work. I used to catch
the train from chatswood down to. Two
muslims points straight off the train into
the into work and. Then if i had to go
to town like saturday night he makes to
have to make sure that i was home or down
to the key to get the last ferry across
and get the train. From there but i have
missed the last train at times and had to
walk from mrs freud to chatswood that.
You didn't seem to mind. I still like
walking as a matter fact i do we used to do
a lot of walking in the latter years in
the when i was in and other capacity. I
used to walk about a mile and
a half every lunch hour. Do you remember
the extracurricular activities in the
workshops during the lunch hour. Well you
didn't get to change him. I suppose that
sit down where they were working and need
put out their lunch and some of them have
the thermos bag the thermos bottles and
others just boil the billy in there. They
have their town by the time that was oh
you're back to working in. There was there
wasn't too much time because it was only
what half an hour or something like and no
crown and anchor or anything like. I
didn't. Really. There was some games play
but there was i never took part in them.
I thought all. Several people told me
these to get and the
boys used to go down for
a swim in the neutral bay bar. They
probably did but it was really they have to
walk around the train lines to do that. And
one of them swore he used to go and be
right. Love and obey you. Right. But one
of them swore that he used to dive in the
harbor as well although dave evans that
he saw sharks in there. Well that's right
there are a lot of other things used
to see floating around. Which don't be
a mentioning over and over
the air at all. Do you
when you were laid off. We never on the
dole. I was too young to go on the dole at
that stage. So i wanted to
do. I used to go around it
a little bit of gardening
doing a little bit of there's
a little bit of that you know
anything i could do to earn
a few shillings at that time and go around
neighbors and that sort of thing you
want some gardening done or anything.
I've jobs jobs done. You live with your
parents to do so i did. Yes and your father
did was he working. He was. Yes he was
working in fact my father's brothers living
with us all the time and he was on the
dole and he was he worked on the. You know
that. Eastern valley highway. As you know
the eastern valley highway was built by
workers and also the epping road it was
built by workers and celente it's park
outside royal north shore hospital
or this and i was able at royal as
a hospital that was built by die workers
to get they get paid. They had to do so
much work to get get their.
Ration tickets. It was there.
That's where it's wrong today and it was
that was done in the two two weeks of work
and five weeks off your
countrymen. I don't remember now.
Yes others. There was quite
a few different systems they had i run the
place that some of the felons have told
me about. Well i never was on the dog.
I wasn't eligible to retire. But i
tried but i wasn't eligible.
Looking back now what do you
think of those days on the bridge. Well
they were good days and i enjoyed the
working there and. I learned
a few skills now and there and which i
think. Abstract i mean. You learn learn
a lot from from the attitude of the people
who are working with because if you
didn't do your job you soon. Knew about
it's new it's not like today where you can
get away with
a lot of things that you could never
get away with in those days it was
a good swift kick in the backside as something
like that. If you didn't do your job
. I'd be right if that happened
there. There would certainly would be
a right now. Do you remember the working
conditions around the workshop for then.
Well in the working conditions in those
they were primitive to working conditions
in these days even the men in jails have
better conditions. I would say than the
work conditions in those days for us if
you want to go to the toilet the toilet.
There was
a block of toilets which we had about
eight or nine rows of toilets on either
side back to back and they had
no doors on them. And they
surround of it was only about six or seven
feet high. So that you got all the cold
breeze well for harboring it into there
and. The foreman used to walk around
occasionally have a look around see if
you been in there too long or if you got
a new got
a paper and if you thought you'd been there
too long. It used to make you stand up
and able to go down the aisle. So
you had to be very careful of your
behaviour which you. In those in
that respect and they didn't take
to tolerate to you any clowning around
which is it's a good thing because.